guys this show is so fun congratulations
um first of all i do want to know if you
found yourselves
stuck in a musical from the 1940s how
would you handle that does
oh um i mean i think my first thought
would be that like
i'd eaten something or something had
gone wrong
i'd be like what did i do today um
but i i think if i if after a certain
point i was like okay this is my new
reality i'd probably just
join in you know human nature to adapt
and
there's something about the world that i
feel like i would fit in really well
yeah i can see that too aaron what about
you yeah same i think you know
after the initial shock of uh you know
the reality change and reality check
i think i'd lean all the way in i think
that's the only way you could kind of
get through is just to like
totally totally lean in also like come
on
i feel like we would enjoy it like i
think we'd be all right i think
i'd make the best of it yeah yeah always
the singing the dancing you just embrace
it all
absolutely i love that um you know aaron
you have so much experience with musical
theater theater alone
um is this kind of like a dream tv job
for you
absolutely i mean this is uh i think for
you know i could probably say the same
for dove and i
both uh you know we get to kind of walk
in all these different areas but this is
one of those jobs that kind of combines
everything in an amazing way you know
it's kind of a real marriage
of all that we've gotten to do so yeah
it's it's amazing you know and you're
kind of working at the
highest level with the people that are
organizing this and
you know wrote this and directing it and
then you kind of combine the musical
element it's yeah it's a dream come true
you know this is such an impressive cast
i love like the guest stars that came on
dove who were you silently geeking out
about when
uh i think i was not so silently geeking
out about basically everyone
um no truly but when i i am like a freak
fan
of both jane krakowski and alan [ __ ]
i mean i was i was so excited to meet
everybody but the second i heard that
they were involved i was like guys i
i will do anything like i was um
i was very nervous to meet them too it
takes a lot for me to like really get in
that space where i'm like i'm not worthy
i'm sorry for breathing your air
but it's like the talent that those two
possess and the charisma
like you know irreplaceable legends yeah
i can only imagine aaron what about you
yeah i think the same i mean everyone is
uh i really admired and looked up to
everyone but uh
you know for me it was uh you know
keegan was a big one to me you know i've
been a huge fan of key and peel and
and all of his other work so i can and
then again like just you meet these
people and they're even nicer in person
than you ever imagined
they would be so it's really it's a very
cool thing we get to do
which is so nice because that's not
always the case
no it's not but you know dove actually
said this yesterday and i really agree
it's like when you
kind of the the the more work i do kind
of the more successful the people are
the nicer they are generally and it's uh
it's a really nice
it's a it's a nice reminder you know
what i've actually noticed that as well
um this show you know aside from like
the singing and the dancing which is so
fantastic it's really funny
why is a parody about golden age
musicals
so fun for the audience to watch
i think i think i think
this one particularly is because the
characters we play are a little bit
one-dimensional and maybe kind of
caricatures of what
what uh you know these people you might
find in one of these musicals but the
fact that we are
paired up against these super smart
really progressive
current sarcastic comics i think that
those two things together
are it's just such an interesting blend
that i've never really seen or
experienced before and i think it really
sets sets all of us up or sets us down
this great path for comedy
yeah um if you had to be trapped in any
musical in history anything that you've
seen
what would be your ideal musical to be
trapped in
we figured this out yesterday okay for
me for me it would be the light in the
piazza
because 1953 florence italy
what more could you want the romance of
it all i mean that's where i want to be
right now
so i feel like that would be that would
be an incredible music to be trapped
i promise this is not a shameless plug
for my broadway show but
uh i think being in turn of the 20th
century bohemian paris
minus the tuberculosis and the you know
maybe uh living conditions
i think being in that uh bohemian
environment of the moulin rouge would be
pretty pretty great
uh that would be awesome and did you
guys get schmidt like did you get that
title
easy to say really like off the bat or
did it take a little bit to get used to
that title
it took a while actually yeah like we
were all like schmegadoon is okay
okay so we're calling it sh megadoon and
we're all oh am i saying this right also
i still don't know how to spell it i'll
be honest
oh yeah i don't know if there's i don't
know if there's two g's or two
yeah same thing two g's or two one g
yeah it's one yeah it's actually one g
yeah that's the problem i love it guys
thanks so much such a pleasure and i
can't wait for everyone to see this
thank you so much thanks morgan thank
you